who is throng the new Big Bad of the
Star Wars universe is all the
live-action storylines are headed to
their own crossover film directed by
Dave filoni thrawn is becoming more and
more important it was announced that
he's going to be played in live action
by Lars Mickelson who voiced the
character in Star Wars Rebels and his
brother to Galen urso actor mads
Mickelson the character was last seen in
Rebels on his Star Destroyer the Chimera
disappearing into hyperspace with Ezra
Bridger thanks to a group of Pergo
hyperspace whales which also made an
appearance in the Mandalorian season 3.
now you might know some of thrawn's
backstory but let's break down thrawn's
complete history and legends expanded
literature his return to Canon and Star
Wars Rebels and the role he'll be
playing in the upcoming live action
titles thrawn was first introduced in
1991 and Timothy zahn's novel heir to
the Empire the first of the Legends
thrawn Trilogy this was an important
time for Star Wars fandom because it was
eight years after Return of the Jedi and
eight years before the release of The
Phantom Menace so there really wasn't
much Star Wars content being made and
these thrawn novels launched the
expanded universe lore into popularity
in a way that really nothing else had
before 4. in these books thrawn was
introduced as a genius Naval Commander
for the Empire with Captain Pelion at
his side and peleon actually showed up
in the Mandalorian chapter 23 played by
Xander Berkeley the books also showed
how thrawn outmaneuvered the new
Republic even nearly killing Admiral
Akbar until he was finally assassinated
by a bodyguard in the last of the three
books one thing to note in both Legends
and in Canon thrawn has never been
defeated due to being outwitted or
outstrategized but only by being
betrayed or by acts of nature that he
never would have been able to predict
like hyperspace whales he is truly one
of the smartest if not the smartest
strategist in the entire Star Wars
Galaxy in 2015 Disney bought lucasfilm
and they re-categorized all expanded
universe fiction as Legends but in the
years since Dave filoni has gradually
begun to recanonize certain elements
from Legends and titles like Star Wars
Rebels the Mandalorian and the Book of
Boba Fett naturally thrawn was one of
the first of these brought in as the
main antagonist in seasons 3 and 4 of
rebels because of this a broader range
of fans have begun to truly understand
how great thrawn is as the grand Admiral
during the reign of the Empire chasing
down the crew of the ghost on the planet
lothal on this planet his Hope was to
construct a fleet of Thai Defenders with
better shielding and had he been
successful the rebels likely wouldn't
have been able to destroy the Death Star
in the Battle of Yavin Tarkin would have
been able to blow up the rebel base on
Yavin 4 and that would have been the end
of the rebellion and that's exactly the
reason why thrawn is such a threat he's
always the smartest guy in the room
outmatched by no one had he not been
zipped away to hyperspace by the pergil
the rebels probably wouldn't have won
during this Rebels era viewers also got
to see how he's capable of decoding his
enemies by learning about their culture
and their art as is the case when he
captured Harrison Doula and studied her
through the lens of Twilight art he was
also able to get inside Ezra bridger's
head by just learning about his
background on lothal really his
intelligence is displayed from a new
canonical backstory outlined in a new
Trilogy of thrawn books titled thrawned
ascendancy also written by the original
author Timothy Zahn thrawn was born on
the planet rental in the unknown regions
a dangerous and Uncharted region of the
galaxy known to its residents as the
chaos this was a very dangerous place to
navigate due to Supernova black holes
gravity Wells and more thrawn was born
into a poor family among the chiss a
group of blue-skinned red-eyed
individuals and he was given the name
kivu ranuru with the core name of vuron
but he later changed his name to Mithra
narodo or thrawn the chits are unique in
the way they abbreviate names coming
from the inside out as opposed to taking
the first part of the name which
definitely says something about how
complex a thinkers all the chits are
they think of everything from the inside
out thrawn later became an officer for
the chiss ascendancy which was a smaller
Empire ruled by an oligarchy class of
chis during the Clone Wars he quickly
Rose through the ranks of the chiss
ascendancy and actually briefly worked
with Anakin Skywalker on a mission on
bad 2 which is the setting of The
blackspire Outpost in Disney's Galaxy's
Edge when the Clone Wars ended and the
Empire came to power thrawn offered his
services to the Empire believing that it
would somehow benefit the chiss later
down the line as his main goal was to
find the Empire's weaknesses in order to
further the advancement of the chiss
people thrawn quickly Rose through the
ranks of the Empire and was granted the
title of grand Admiral by Palpatine
himself which was a pretty big deal
because the empire fire was known to be
xenophobic and only promote humans to
high-ranking positions for instance
almost all the Admirals and Generals
that we know in the Empire are humans
while those who lead the rebels include
a lot of non-humans such as Admiral
Akbar Admiral ratus and Harrison Doula
so for thrawn to rise past all of that
just shows how intelligent and respected
he really was thrawn's intellect was
further displayed in the book thrawn
ascendancy in which he deduces that
Darth Vader and Anakin Skywalker are the
same person he recognizes Vader by the
way he flies his fighter in a specific
barrel roll which was the same as a
maneuver performed by Anakin Skywalker
in the opening scene of Revenge of the
Sith although it was one of the best
kept secrets in the Galaxy thrawn
recognized Vader as Anakin and certainly
use that information to make better
informed decisions thrawn later became
the commanding officer of the seventh
fleet and led the fight against the
rebels in the lothal sector during the
Galactic Civil War he proposed the
creation of the Thai Defender a
Starfighter bomber with Advanced
shielding capabilities and he worked to
see it initially manufactured on lothal
before being mass produced throughout
the Galaxy following the Battle of
atalon the emperor summoned thrawn and
Darth later for a mission to rescue a
group of four sensitive chiss girls
enslaved by the grisk species after this
Mission he resumed his efforts to
eliminate sendula's Rebel cell on lothal
and during the final battle his ship was
pulled into hyperspace by A Flock of
Pergo creatures taking thrawn and the
Padawan Ezra Bridger deep into the
unknown regions now in the live-action
titles Ahsoka Tano was the first to
bring up thrawn's name in the
Mandalorian chapter 13. demanding
thrawn's location from his servant
magistrate Morgan Ellsworth clearly
Ahsoka is still searching for Ezra
Bridger after she and Sabine Wren teamed
up at the end of rebels to find him and
it looks like that search will likely be
renewed in the Ahsoka series thrawn
appeared in the trailer for this Ahsoka
spin-off series shown only from behind
but a frontal image of thrawn's face was
shown exclusively to fans at Star Wars
celebration additionally Captain Pelion
appeared in moff Gideon's Shadow Council
of Imperial Warlords in the final
episodes of season 3 of the Mandalorian
insisting on thrawn's return to Rally
the scattered Imperial supporters across
the Galaxy MAF Gideon dismissed thrawn
as a ghost but it definitely looks like
thrawn is making a comeback so why is
this such a big deal now well after long
line of seemingly incompetent villains
we need someone who is actually smart to
challenge all the heroes we've met so
far between some of the poorly written
villains of the sequel Trilogy to the
more childish characters of The Animated
and Disney plus series we need a
military strategist without a cult-like
subservience to Palpatine or a fear of
Palpatine's ghost we need a cunning and
ruthless character with a brilliant
tactical mind we need thrawn
foreign